[Music]
you know what's interesting is that I
figured out because I was on stage the
other night doing stand-up and I was
starting to do Trump and I figured out
the way I got Trump I started with you
yeah
then I added Brando and that gave me
Trump can you do a little Trump for us
if you hit with Regis you're talking
like this man you gonna Brando you're
kind of like this
that's right now I can to kind of go you
know what Brando and you move yourself
you're Regis and you're right here okay
you're tremendous don't be rude jumping
you're very nice
very nasty okay get the one of the good
ones yeah what are the good ones
terrific if you then divide you're
fabulous
you've got to admit I mean Trump is I
know he's a friend of yours long time
yeah whatever your politics are your
lizard brain just like some of the stuff
he does because when when you know they
took our undersea drone the Chinese yeah
yeah Obama's people are like what we're
gonna we're gonna do what we can and
work with the appropriate authorities to
stabilize them get back the mothers of
ego and the wit we can do it and Trump
just tweets they can keep it
[Applause]